did apple really just send me the wrong
graphics card wanna cost over five g's
apple finally released big navi for
their mac pros and today we're gonna
test out this 2
800. graphics card and see how it
compares to the previous vega 2 in a
variety of tasks like gaming video
editing gpu rendering and things like
that and yes i do still have the mac pro
nobody wants to buy it so i guess i'm
just stuck with it unless one of you
guys do reach out i gotta say this
packaging is insane this box is super
durable and it came in one that was
twice the size and what is this okay
nice so they do include this this is
their infinity fabric link that has
crazy bandwidth if you're connecting two
of these graphics cards together so that
they actually perform really well
without being model neck it's like solid
aluminum here let's get this bad boy out
whoa that was cool
look at that angelica
that's what you get for 2800 bucks the
box literally is
like uh i don't know what they call it
transformative like a transformer this
thing is very heavy look at that
fanless no fan at all this is one nice
thing about the mac pro that it's
basically silent we have large fans that
were just run slowly um
what is this
this says 6 900 x on it
that is not what i ordered and that's
not what arrived at my office angelica
look at that did apple send me the wrong
one or did i order the wrong one i'm
pretty sure i did not pay five thousand
six hundred dollars
for this maybe that's why it's so heavy
um let's check the box yeah w 6800 x
right there angelica get a close-up of
that and on the card
as you guys could see it says
6900x so did apple really just send me
the wrong graphics card wanna cost over
five g's or did they just print the
wrong label on my graphics card and it's
actually a 6800x
inside of here i guess we'll just have
to find out but if this is a w5900x does
that mean that i can't sell my mac pro
because this is just too good of a deal
for a graphics card like this i guess
we'll have to find out so let's go ahead
and open this up i love how easy it is
to
open up these mac pros but it is pretty
heavy let's spin this bad boy around and
admire the beauty of apple engineering
we have our vega two right here i love
the attention to detail and how they
just stay in place they don't just come
out here let's get the last one and the
last step is just to undo this little
latch
unlock whoops i lied there are two more
on this side that i missed
let's get these out
bam and now
with one little latch
bam pops out surprisingly there's very
little dust in here that looks super
clean it's also very heavy let's see
which one is heavier
is it the new one or oh yeah oh this
thing is way heavier surprisingly what
if it's a duo and they put the wrong
label on it what if it's both
let's hope for that but let's go ahead
and pop it in get our case on
one little twist and we are done now i'm
gonna go ahead and go and grab my
display all right we have the 6k xdr
screen here can't believe that graphics
card it looked it up it actually cost
six grand the same as six this display
with the stand all right we're getting
close the moment of truth did apple
actually send me a six thousand dollar
graphics card i kind of hope they didn't
because that means that i'd want to keep
it
and i'd want to keep this mac bro
which i don't want to do my heart is
actually beating right now
to see which one it is
about the smack and
oh
okay
gosh this is the most bittersweet moment
so as you guys could see
it does say
w6800x so it is not the 6900 so they
didn't send me the right box
and the right card it just doesn't have
the right label printed on the card well
that's fine we could still get a 6900x
and compare it to this one and then also
the
w5700x so if you guys want to see that
comparison click that subscribe button
down below maybe we'll do a gaming video
as well if you guys want to see it
and that will also help us reach a
million subscribers before the end of
the year but for now that was just a
huge roller coaster let's go in and see
how this thing actually performs the
first thing i want to do is our classic
geekbench 5 let's see what our metal
score is going to be
switch over to compute here bam yep it's
the 6800x we're gonna switch it to metal
and run all right results are coming in
and a hundred and thirty seven thousand
two hundred so the previous vega two
that i have that one got about a hundred
thousand sometimes ninety six thousand
so that's actually a pretty good
improvement about forty percent faster
and it's actually the same price as well
now it's kind of weird that it is the
same price because this thing uses gddr6
memory 32 gigabytes of it which is a lot
but it's not the very expensive hbm2 so
i would think that the prices would
actually go down but i guess in this
current market where graphics cards are
selling for three thousand dollars for
gaming cards i guess it makes sense if
they kept it the same now the next test
i want to run is another classic unigine
heaven we're using the extreme preset
this is one that we haven't been able to
use since the m1s came out because they
don't support opengl but we'll also do
another gaming test using metal as well
and this is one area where this new
graphics card could be a lot faster
because of efficiency oh
no no no okay that's a second driver
issue we're having huh i guess we're
gonna force restart this thing apple's
actually the one that makes the drivers
and controls that's not amd anymore and
this is the latest version of mac os not
the beta let's give this another go
hopefully it doesn't crash take a look
at that guys this thing is running
incredibly cool we're at 47 degrees
celsius 46. it's just hovering around
there where's my previous one it was
about 80 the big oh
that's it i guess we can't do this test
but from what i could see it is just
running very very cool so maybe that's
another benefit not that we had issues
before switching over to base mark gpu
test this is a gaming test using metal
so it looks like old games are no longer
compatible with these new expensive
graphics cards i have a set to high here
let's go ahead and see how it handles it
man that lighting graphics look really
nice
on this 6k display
we have a score of 12
351
and you can actually download basemark's
gpu test for your mac and see how your
you know mac performs with this it looks
like about 45 faster
than the vega 2 that i have so it is a
pretty good improvement and now let's
get a little bit more serious we have
the blender benchmark here that could do
the graphics test i selected our brand
new not
unfortunately now uh let's see how this
thing can do all right and bam now that
is a good improvement we had 40 45
before this is more than twice as fast 7
minutes 24 seconds compared to 15
minutes and 59 seconds for the vega 2
more than twice as fast so maybe this is
when you have a heavy workflow you're
doing rendering this is where this new
graphics card is really going to kick in
let's try another 3d rendering program
we have octane right here which is great
i'm going to do a couple of the default
ones just in case you guys want to
compare it to your systems let's do the
trench benchmark here see how long this
takes so that took 29 seconds and let's
test out the chess set wow all right 10
seconds right there that is really good
improvement compared to 18 seconds so
almost twice as fast so it looks like
this big navi card is a rendering
beast and now finally video editing you
guys know we do a ton of that here at
max tech this is what matters most so
hopefully we have a good improvement we
are going to start out right here with
bruce x this is going to test the video
editing rendering performance of this
graphics card just the raw performance
bam okay that was actually slow that was
actually pretty dang slow that took 10
seconds compared to six with the vega
two let me go ahead and just run this
one more time bam
six seconds okay from 10 seconds down to
six how can you have that second run is
almost twice as fast let's try it one
more time it's probably gonna stay right
around there okay yep six seconds again
so no improvement there just for
rendering this but maybe 5k is no longer
enough maybe we need a 12k bruce x test
so bruce x whoever you are maybe you can
give us an update and now for some
standard 4k of course it's not gonna
have any issues playing this back the m1
just slays this but what i'm curious
about is did amd upgrade the encoders in
this graphics card that were the main
limitation with the vega 2 so let's go
ahead and export this as far as graphics
power look at that
32 gigs of graphics memory is maxed out
but the processor is being used
barely anything let's see what is that
right there 10
we're using 10 of that graphics card i'm
going to be very curious what the result
is the cpu usage is only at 14
interesting bam
okay
well that took two minutes and 37
seconds and that is pretty much
identical to the two minutes and 30
seconds that the vega 2 took so looks
like as far as exporting the encoders
have not gotten any better at least for
standard h.264 footage those are
identical so that is a little bit of a
disappointment now i'm doing the same
thing with the hevc or h.265 project so
more efficient higher compressed codec
maybe will have some differences and
here it looks like the gpu usage is even
lower we are sitting at five percent
graphics usage now and this just proves
to you guys if you're working with this
kind of standard footage that most
people work with you don't really need
one of these crazy graphics cards or
these systems the m1 is killer for this
and bam that was done
two minutes and 44 seconds and
previously i believe that was two
minutes and 30 seconds as well so this
is actually a little bit slower this
time
what is going on all right i think what
we need to do is throw something that's
actually difficult at this system let's
go ahead and take a let's look at some
canon raw footage
this right here has a couple luts
applied well actually one lot some other
corrections
playback perfectly with this actually 4k
60 frames per second raw footage
and look at that it looks like the
graphics card
it's only using 26 so we have a lot of
overhead here a lot more than the vega
2. now let's go ahead and export this
bad boy bam it is done four minutes and
35 seconds compared to five minutes so
not much faster once again the graphics
card surprisingly wasn't maxed out doing
this so even this is just way too easy
for it so all right guys what do we do
next do we go to
the 4.5 k raw i guess let's do that one
first look at that perfectly smooth i'm
used to seeing this being choppy on the
m1 max and we're only using 21 of the
graphics card uh right there hit 24 and
this is actually in better quality not
better performance this is full quality
no issues there and then as we're
exporting look it's still only using 38
of the graphics card
what is the deal here even with this
footage all right there you go finally
even if the graphics are not even
halfway used we have three minutes and
20 seconds compared to 5 minutes and 6
seconds that is a 53 improvement in
performance that is actually massive but
now let's throw the big guns at it let's
open up this 8k test the vega 2 which
was the best single graphics card you
can get could not play this back
perfectly smooth
let's try this guy out nope if you guys
see that there are still a few stutters
that show up it's almost perfectly
smooth but with that the graphics card
still it's only 54 why not use the extra
performance to play this back perfectly
clearly it's there the vega 2 was
actually maxed out completely when i was
doing this and for the final test we're
gonna export out to prores we're not
going to be working with a compressed
kodak let's see if we can make full use
of this graphics card in this way nope
still only 51
graphics usage
that is a bummer i wonder what the
limitation is our ram is maxed out 32
gigs of memories maxed out maybe the
memory is too slow maybe the drivers
suck we saw those crashes happen maybe
apple has more tweaking to do
but it just sucks seeing that when you
spent so much money that was six minutes
compared to seven minutes and 30 seconds
so finally we have a bigger difference
uh with an export but you got to be
working with 8k
redraw now i do think in the future it
will be faster so you know what i have a
lot more work to do i want to bust out
the prores raw 8k that might make a
bigger difference some canon c200 or
canon r5 footage see if it can handle
that without being a choppy mess like my
vega graphics card and of course test
out the more expensive 6900 which i
didn't receive unfortunately and also
the less expensive 1 000
5700 x or the w version of that so if
you guys want to see that click that
circle above to subscribe and you guys
can help us reach 1 million subscribers
before the end of the year check out one
of those other great videos right over
there this has been max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]